what was it specifically about that
moment that made you suddenly grasp onto
this because it seems like that was
somewhat immediate am I wrong yes and no
okay um the less you know the better off
you are at the beginning because you're
more innocent and and more curious I'm
definitely a very curious person clearly
but I was fascinated by somebody who
would accomplish so much at such a early
part of cinema but not not even the
early cinema part the fact that she was
an artist and an entrepreneur personally
related to that but I felt that I needed
to do work or somehow what could I do to
help get her more known and I was
actually talking to Robert Redford
because my day job is I do graphics so
now you know the secret to the the
secret sauce behind some of this and I
was working on one of his films and I
asked him what do you think we should do
and and I said I think maybe we should
do a documentary of course if I went
back in time I'd probably shoot myself
but it's never a full like aha moment it
takes kind of time to brew can I do this
do do I know what I'm doing am I going
to find anything and then you know you
align yourself with people such as you
know Joan Simon and the many other
people that we stand on their shoulders
that have worked on her an hours before
in pieces I read her memoirs and that's
kind of what became the moment for me
but I didn't realize that my oh yeah
would take me all the way here
what were the things that you found or
what was the the fine that kind of gave
you put you over the hump in feeling
like you were on to more truth with
Alice one of the amazing things about
this project is that we started on
Kickstarter and were completely donation
based and we have people in the audience
that are donors to the film because of
the freedom that I had with the donors
helping me along the way I was able to
for the first time collect all of the
work as much as possible in the
different archives over the years
transfer them get the rights and show
them for the first time in one film the
the most of her work and the clips might
be short yes I like fast paced cutting
but I was so eager to show how much this
woman had done you know I got carried
away myself oh my god I'm going to show
this one I'm gonna show that one but
also in the format's were a mess you
know Dino Everett who's in the audience
they bring a b-natural shirt ahead of
the Hugh Hefner archives at USC he had
to reformat all the film's you know it's
not a one-person job
it's an army you saw the end crawl so
just because the films were available it
doesn't mean that they were ever seen by
the mass audience and you know I want
everybody to know about ours yes she is
part of history and silent cinema and
I've tried to yank her out of that a
little bit so people can get to know her
as a human being as an artist and an
entrepreneur I can't yank her out
completely but I've definitely broadened
her base and for a younger audience and
and people that are you don't have to be
necessarily an expert in in cinema you
should like her for her creativity and
for her determination and tenacity but I
think you've also pulled her in two
directions out to the wide public but
now her name is among three Lumiere
Melies Alice keep blushing as a curator
editor and now writer producer you've
consistently worked to bring the work of
women in the arts into the popular gaze
what initiated this interest and do you
plan to continue on this path and how
does Alice fit into that thank you for
the question I've done it for almost 40
years now
back in the early
there was a very common phrase Anonymous
was a woman mm-hmm and many people
started to attach their name to their
work and to put it in the field of
vision when I worked on a magazine we
made sure we looked at a range of shows
women were writing men were writing it
was a beginning beginning to write books
because they last longer than magazine
articles working in film in museums and
you know and with other publishers
they're all different channels but the
process is the same and the goal is the
same and yes the answer is affirm yes
when you see what they were originally
like on the screen and you have music
and you have the good pieces then you're
certainly not only doing archaeology of
what was but you take it a step further
and have contemporary filmmakers who are
thinking in the visual terms that a
filmmaker thinks in so you spent a lot
of time doing that what was the key to
getting a lot of these people to
participate in this well when I first
compared the early cinema to YouTube
filmmakers I think there was a wanted
sign on my head in the send a file
archive world because they did not like
that they did not like that approach so
I needed to find the right person that
saw what I saw and Deno of course always
saw that you know Everett Henry Jenkins
who was he was a person who discussed it
and when I looked at it I was like these
do look like SNL shorts and the thing is
if you're watching a film and you want
to learn about a woman and you want to
learn about the context and the error
etc if you don't make it relatable
people going to tune out so when I
looked at it that's the way I felt so
that's why I project it and as far as
getting the people I took a lot of work
they had to go to hours key blush a
school every time there's nobody that's
in there
it's fake they all had to read I had
this binder that I would take to each
meeting and show them all the different
things that to watch all the films they
were along the journey with me together
we were all learning about Alice qiblah
Shay so that was very important to me to
keep it honest and for anybody from any
walk of life if you're you know into
construction a plumber or whatever you
shouldn't feel weird to watch a
documentary and ever feel uncomfortable
if you don't know something because I
have felt that way in documentaries oh
my god I don't know who this person is
and they're talking about him now I have
to look it up and I never wanted anybody
to watch this film and not know who what
where and ever feel like oh you know I
don't know anything about cinema well
you don't have to because I'm gonna walk
you through the whole thing and they can
go watch it again do you believe the
landscape of cinema and specifically for
cinema for women would be different had
Alice gave Alice qiblas a story and work
not been lost to history and how would
it be different I had her story been a
part of the narrative from her story and
many stories I mean if you notice in the
film three times Dino says why are we
showing but you know restoring
metropolis for like the 50th time does
all these other women we should know
about I think absolutely my dream was to
be here to have a screening my dream
will be at the Museum that when people
walk in that they see Lumiere my liaison
hours and then later because she had a
22 career 22-year career and women were
not documented or recorded so not just
women directors but women writers there
were in every part of architects you
know
so hopefully this yes editors so
hopefully with this film it can push and
help other projects that have to do in
silent cinema or other projects to get
these stories told in and made thank you
so much for sharing your film with us